This website got hit by Google core
update. It went from getting 124,000
organic visitors per month to 30,000
organic visitors. But as you can see
here, it's now improving and it's now
recovering the search traffic and the
keywords lost. In today's video, I'll be
showing you exactly what you need to do
to allow your website to recover from
the Google Core update if you've been
hit. So, if you actually want to go
ahead and get a full audit, we created
this skill, which all you need to do is
enter in your website if you've been hit
by any Google core update, and it'll do
an audit for you and tell you exactly
what you need to do and create a plan
for you to follow to improve your
website ranking and keywords.
If you want to get the skill, just
comment Google core update below and
I'll send it over to you. Now, let's
talk about exactly what we did to
recover this website. The first thing
that we did was we wanted to solidify
the rankings that we already had and
that was not hit. So we went over to our
top pages and we improved all of the
content on our top pages. So for
example, if I go ahead and open up this
link, I can see my article here. Now the
easiest way to improve your content is
actually to use Word Rocket. So Word
Rocket has a improve content feature.
So, if we head over to generate content
and transform with our content improver,
we can scrape the URL.
So, you copy over your URL. Click
scrape.
And then you're going to get the full
article here. So, then we can go ahead
and tell it, okay, we want the word
count to be less or more. We can change
up the tonality. We can change up the
model. We can expand and deepen. We can
add advanced settings like geo
optimization, HTML widget, brand voice,
internal linking, remove that references
and citations. And if you want to
generate images, you can. It's easy for
you to update your articles that are
doing well. So, if you have 10, 15, 20
articles that are doing well, you can
simply pop it into Word Rocket and then
update the content and you'll get fresh,
up-to-date 2026 information because
Google loves fresh and up-to-date
content. So that was the first thing
that we did. The second thing that we
did was we focus on creating content on
other platforms other than just for
Google SEO or blogging. So if we take a
look at some of our top articles here,
we also went ahead and turned them into
engaging and useful videos. So if I go
ahead and take a look at this article,
>> have you ever spotted a strange kind of
>> We can see that this is actually a
really really well done video. And this
video got us 8.1,000
views within the last couple of months.
So this is a really really good uh trust
signal as well uh because Google is
going to look at your website from a
holistic approach not just only from
Google or what you're doing on your
website. So because we've went ahead and
we've create created YouTube videos and
we also went ahead and created a whole
channel. So we focus on multi-
channelannel um content as well. So, we
see here that these videos get a good
amount of views. 54,000 video uh video
views, 50,000 video views down the key
differences between two commonauses
>> actual um video. In the description,
we've went ahead and linked back to our
website. So, again, another really
really good um SEO factor there. And
this also allows you to get more
targeted traffic because maybe your blog
post is not going to rank, but maybe
your video ranks. And that is how people
see your brand and that's how you can
get more um targeted SEO traffic as
well. So we did the same thing for
Instagram. We created Instagram reels,
Instagram post and we also created a
bunch of questions and threads in Reddit
and Kora. So we focus on not just only
um SEO on the website side of things, we
also focus on creating content in other
places. And I believe that really really
helped us to get traffic from other
places not just only solely from our
website but also helps with our EAT our
trust factor and Google looking at our
holistic SEO and choosing to then give
us more rankings and recovering our
traffic.
So that is the second thing that we did.
The third thing is related to that and
we also went ahead over to our website
and we just added more trust factors. So
we added in pictures of our doctors. We
added in more information about the
doctors and their qualifications. Um
just again showing that we are an
authority within this space and the
website has people that are authority
within that space and that again allows
Google to get much higher trust factors
and trust signals to allow us to have a
better chance at recovering. So, if you
have the ability to do so, I would
definitely try to see how you can add in
industry leaders or people that have
very specific certifications within your
niche on your website. The next thing
that we did was we focused on increasing
our backlinks, but not just trash
backlinks, but backlinks that are
actually important to our niche. Because
this is the health niche, we're able to
strategically reach out to partners. We
got a big backlink from very well health
which is a humongous website. We also
were able to get a backlink from
Melanoma Canada which is a huge huge
wellrespected site on Google. So if you
are a real business I definitely
recommend trying to get strategic
partnerships. So you write something
about um a specific brand or specific
business or a specific certification on
your site and then have them write about
you as well and have them link back to
your website. The fourth thing that I
recommend is that you do not stop
creating new articles and creating new
blog posts. So, we actually didn't stop
creating new articles or even creating
new pages. If you look at our blog CMS,
we've continued to create articles and
blog post because we want Google to see
that we are an authority within this
space that we we want to own topical
authority. We want Google to look at our
website as an encyclopedia about this
specific niche. So that means you need
to continue writing highquality SEO
optimized content. And of course, I'm
going to recommend using Word Rocket
because it is the best content writer in
the market. You need to continue posting
at least 30 to 40 articles every single
month on your website and also creating
new pages on your site if you can. So,
if you're a local business, I also
recommend continuing to create new local
targeted pages for within cities if that
is relevant to you or within towns or
even within countries. This gives you a
better chance of getting new rankings
and ranking for new keywords and new
topics to help offset some of the
keywords or some of the topics that you
may have lost in a Google core update.
And we know SEO takes time. So, by
continuing to create these articles, you
continue to give your chance to get more
rankings in the future if you lose out
on some rankings from the past. And my
last tip would be to just stay patient.
It can be hard to see your website drop
off, but if you continue to do the
things that I mentioned in today's
video, if you continue to put the work
into your website and really treat it
like a real business and take a
comprehensive SEO strategy and much more
multi- channelannel than just, you know,
getting articles and blog posts on
Google. So, if you do these steps that I
mentioned in today's video and you take
the time out and you're a little bit
patient, I guarantee you your website
will start to improve time after time.
It may take a couple of months and you
continue to focus on what you can
control. Eventually, your websites will
start to recover and hopefully even pass
your all-time high. Hope that you guys
enjoyed today's video. If you did, let
me know by giving us a big thumbs up and
I'll see you in the next one. Take care.